ROBERTS AND TALK THAT THE
HISTORIC SUMMIT COULD STILL
HAPPEN.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> GOOD EVENING TO YOU,
MIKE.
LAST WEEK A TEAM FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE WENT TO
SINGAPORE TO MEET WITH THE
NORTH KOREANS TO SET UP THE
WHOLE SUMMIT.
THAT TEAM SAT ON THE GROUND
FOR THREE DAYS.
THE NORTH KOREANS NEVER
SHOWED THERE WAS WORD THAT
THEY WERE GOING TO GO BACK
AGAIN TONIGHT.
THAT WAS OFF AND BACK ON.
NOW THERE IS TALK SWIRLING
AROUND THE WHITE HOUSE THAT,
IN FACT, THAT TEAM MAY BE
HEADED BACK TO SINGAPORE TO
MEET WITH THE NORTH KOREANS
TO GET THIS SUMMIT BACK ON
TRACK SOME TIME THIS
WEEKEND.
>> WHAT A DIFFERENCE A DAY
MAKES.
24 HOURS AFTER HE SENT A
LETTER TO KIM JONG UN
CANCELING THEIR SUMMIT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY SAID
IT MIGHT BE BACK ON.
>> WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
WE'RE TALKING TO THEM NOW.
IT WAS A VERY NICE STATEMENT
THEY PUT OUT.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IT COULD EVEN BE THE 12TH.
WE ARE TALKING TO THEM NOW.
THEY VERY MUCH WANT TO DO
IT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO DO IT.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> TURN AROUND HAPPENED
AFTER UNCHARACTERISTICALLY
DIPLOMATIC RESPONSE FROM
NORTH KOREA TO THE LETTER.
NORTH KOREA SAYING IT IS
STILL WILLING TO MEET THE
U.S. AT ANY TIME IN ANY
FORMAT ADDING WE REMAIN
UNCHANGED IN OUR WILLINGNESS
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN FOR
THE PEACE AND STABILITY OF
THE KOREAN PENINSULA.
WE ARE WILLING TO GIVE THE
UNITED STATES TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDING
IN KIND ON TWITTER, QUOTE:
VERY GOOD NEWS TO RECEIVE
THE WARM AND PRODUCTIVE
STATEMENT FROM NORTH KOREA.
WE WILL SOON SEE WHERE IT
WILL LEAD.
HOPEFULLY TO LONG AND
ENDURING PROSPERITY AND
PEACE.
ONLY TIME AND TALENT WILL
TELL.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, AIDES
RUSHED TO CONTACT THEIR
COURT PARTS IN NORTH KOREA
TO TRY TO PUT THINGS BACK
TOGETHER FOR JUNE 129.
WITH THE CAVEAT THAT NORTH
KOREA NEEDS TO BE SERIOUS
ABOUT COMING TO THE TABLE.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT SAID
THIS MORNING, CERTAINLY WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
MEETING, BUT THE PRESIDENT
IS NOT JUST LOOKING TO HAVE
A MEETING, HE IS NOT LOOKING
FOR JUST A CHEAP POLITICAL
STUNT, HE WANTS TO GET
SOMETHING THAT'S A
LONG-LASTING AND ACTUAL REAL
SOLUTION.
>> AS THE WHITE HOUSE
PREPARED TO SEND BACK TO
SINGAPORE AN ADVANCE TEAM
THE NORTH KOREANS STOOD UP
LAST WEEKEND, DEMOCRATS SAID
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE
USED THAT AS THE REASON FOR
POSTPONING THE SUMMIT RATHER
THAN THE WHITE HOUSE STATED
RATIONALE FOR CANCELING IT
THAT THERE SHOULD BE NO
MEETING WITH NORTH KOREAN
OFFICIALS ARE GOING TO
THREATEN NUCLEAR
CONFRONTATION.
>> WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE DONE
IS SIMPLY ANNOUNCED THAT WE
WERE DELAYING THE SUMMIT TO
A DATE NOT DESIGNATED AND
SAY OUT REASON FOR IT WAS
THAT THEY DIDN'T SHOW UP TO
THE PLANNING MEETING.
IF THEY DON'T SHOW UP TO THE
PLANNING MEETING IT'S HARD
TO PLAN AND GET THINGS DONE
BY JUNE 129.
BUT, BY CANCELING IT, IT
MAKES THEM LOOK LIKE THEY
ARE MORE INTERESTED IN PEACE
THAN WE ARE.
THAT'S A MISTAKE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP TELLS FOX
NEWS HE HAS REACHED A DEAL
TO SAVE CHINESE TELECOM
GIANT ZTE.
AFTER THE U.S. COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT SHUTTERED ZTE FOR
SANCTIONS VIOLATIONS IN
NORTH KOREA AND IRAN.
XI CALLED PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO.
XI INITIALLY OFFERED A FINE
OF $500 MILLION AND CHANGE
OUT THE MANAGEMENT AND BOARD
OF ZTE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTED THE
FINE BE HIGHER, 1.5 BILLION
IN ADDITION TO MANAGEMENT
AND BOARD CHANGES, PRESIDENT
TRUMP ALSO WANTED SECURITY
GUARANTEES AND A PROMISE
THAT ZTE WILL BUY MOST OF
ITS COMPONENTS FROM U.S.
COMPANIES.
XI COUNTERED WITH A
BILLION-DOLLAR FINE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOLD FOX
NEWS THEY EVENTUALLY SETTLED
ON 1.3 BILLION.
THE ANNOUNCEMENT OF A DEAL
DREW FIRE FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN PARTY.
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO
TWEETING:  YES, THEY HAVE A
DEAL IN MIND.
IT'S A GREAT DEAL FOR ZTE
AND CHINA.
CHINA CRUSHES U.S. COMPANIES
WITH NO MERCY AND THEY USE
THESE TELECOM COMPANIES TO
SPY AND STEAL FROM US.
MANY HOPES THIS TIME WOULD
BE DIFFERENT.
NOW CONGRESS WILL NEED TO
ACT.
NOT SURPRISINGLY DEMOCRATS
WERE CRITICAL OF THE DEAL AS
WELL THE HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER NANCY PELOSI CALLING
IT, QUOTE, STAGGERING
BETRAYAL OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTED TO
FOX NEWS THAT HE HAS BEEN
FAR TOUGHER ON ZTE THAN THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION EVER
WAS.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
RECENTLY CONSIDERED
SANCTIONS AGAINST ZTE AND
THEN BACKED OFF.